alcamo is a little town a half away
between trapani and palermo in sicily
pretty known for its nice sandy beach on
the gulf of castellamare on that
specific night in the carabinieris
barracks the alcamar two officers are
sleeping the deputy salvatore falcita
from casta vetrano and the 19 year old
boy carmine apuzzo from castellamar of
stabia it's a stormy night around 7 am
on the morning of january 27
1976 the carabineri car escorting
giorgio almirante passing by notices
that in the barracks something is wrong
the front door has been first opened
using a blowtorch called immediately the
police entered the carbonyl station and
found a gruesome scene carmine is lying
in his coat riddled with bullets he
didn't even notice what was happening
sartori on the other hand hears the
noises tries to reach for his gun but
doesn't make it in time
guns uniforms and other items are
missing from the barracks it is a
marginal event in a remote village in a
region that has far more remarkable
killings to remember but the affair is
disturbing because of its consequences
and due to the fact that even today so
many years later no one knows the reason
for this massacre of course speculation
has been made and some stories have
emerged and that's what i want to talk
about with you today regarding that
massacre there's still no clue about the
real perpetrators too bad these people
were innocent the atmosphere that theirs
in italy in those years is not the
easiest it's called the years of lead
not by chance the danger of terrorism
the red brigades the mafia the twisted
secret services that was basically italy
wasn't who was
sure anyway it was winter in alabama
an ideal place and situation for
landings of smuggled cigarettes drugs
and perhaps even weapons the
investigator's first suspicion fell on
the red brigades although to be fair
there was a claim by a group never heard
of before a few hours after the massacre
in fact the nucleus ichiri armada
broadcasted this telephone message in an
inflected tone of voice to the
switchboard operator of the newspaper la
sicilia la justice
a message that investigators gave little
way to no one will ever hear from this
group again it was a red herring but the
caller had seen or maybe knew full well
what had happened in the barracks three
days later the red brigades
disassociated themselves from the action
and that lead died then the police got a
plot twist at checkpoint a young man
giuseppewsku called pino originally from
alchemy was stopped in a fiat 127 with a
false license plate he is an odd one to
the extent that his fellow citizens call
him crazy giuseppe he's missing his left
hand blown up along with a device he had
detonated in a meadow they found the
name a gun a 7 16 5 caliber the same
kind used in the massacre of the two
carbineeri and then another pistol a
bereza supply to the coronary forces the
conclusion is obvious it was him pino
sits in absolute silence broken only by
rambling phrases such as i consider
myself a prisoner of war then at the
trial he retracted everything for the
press he's the monster but the question
is what happened between the arrest and
the trial to understand this we can take
a look at the letters penis hands from
prison to his mother even though often
there's no addressing what came up at
first at least was the figure of a pro
italian fighter red brigade's style and
so it was in this direction that the
investigation moved but pino also has an
obsession they he says want to kill me
making me look crazy and locking me up
in an asylum and he spoke about the
torture by the cabinetry he endured
during the interrogation he did so with
extraordinary lucidity after being
stretched between two boxes he confesses
that he was poured a liquid down his
throat with a large funnel it was used
to simulate suffocation pina is not a
hero like the ones we see in the movies
resisting great tortures so the
carabinieri get what they want the
hiding place where the guns the uniforms
and what not are collected but that's
not enough the carbonary won the name of
the accomplices and so the torture
starts again eventually he can't take it
any longer and calls out four random
names those of four friends with whom he
occasionally spends his free time at his
own trial he will deny everything but a
carabineri murder is not something one
can understate so he ends up in jail
while his alleged accomplices are sold
speaking of confessions in 2007 32 years
after the events a former carabinieri a
certain renato oino went over vasco's
interrogation reporting on the torture
exactly as he had described it but more
on this later assembly
mafia
the names given by the tortured vesco
are giovanni mandela a fireworks maker
vincenzo ferrantelli gaetano santangelo
giuseppe gulotta four friends a couple
still miners who knew nothing at all
about politics and armed struggle yet
they too confess then at the trial they
will say that their depositions are the
result of heavy torture suffered during
their interrogations pino will not make
it to this trial he died in prison by
hanging in his cell the sentence was
immediate it was suicide how he made the
slipknots and everything else with only
one hand remains a mystery a mystery
that investigators do not seem to care
about at all but the other four remained
as they awaited their appeal the two
miners varentalia santangelo fled to
brazil seeking political asylum the
sentences on appeal were harsh 20 years
for the fugitives life imprisonment for
the others santa angelo would return
home in 1995 mandala would die in prison
of illness while gulotta would go to
life imprisonment
in short a psychological torture
eventually in november 1989 he was
locked up in prison where he would have
to spend the rest of his life
unless unless this during one of the
many review trials a former carabiner
comes forward as a witness he has much
to tell the year is 2008 32 years have
passed since the alcohol massacre and
gulata has been in prison for more than
18 years he has certainly aged but is
still hoping for some judge to prove his
innocence because none of those who were
arrested had anything to do with those
killings the former carabinero's name is
giuseppe ulino and what he recounts is
gruesome the torture took place
including electric shocks to the
genitals with the presence of a doctor
who determined when to suspend and want
to begin again the torture with military
and weapon officers whose misconduct was
so close to the methods of the spanish
inquisition olin also said to disagree
with that torture so why wait 32 years
to spill the beans also interesting is
the choice of targets to pursue during
the investigation those to be attacked
were leftist formations even known
extreme ones orlino even recalled a
search at the home of pepino impastato
journalist and fierce antagonist of the
mafia in the town of chinese there is
the mafia led by tanoba lamenti and it
was pepino himself who would distribute
a very critical leaflet in which she
wondered why the mafia wasn't fully
considered guilty for that crime all
that remains is speculation lots of
speculation evolving from time to time
the italian state the mafia and
smuggling of the secret services there
is the suicide of pinovescu there is the
discovery of the bodies of the two
carabineri and how is that all mirantis
guards drive past the barracks that very
morning why does the court bluntly
condemn four thugs who have no record
while it's clear that the murder was
organized by prepared people olina's
depositions sparked new investigations
and lead to a new trial on february 2012
this happens
after more than 22 years in prison as an
innocent man giuseppe gulotta is
released from prison and compensated
with six and a half million euros i need
to make a remark about the many
mysteries of our republic which is full
of depredations false evidence almost
always done to protect someone or
something we even had to say that glotta
was lucky even though he was deprived
for a very long time of the most
precious asset we have in life our own
freedom at that time deputy prosecutor
antonio ingroya was working in the city
of tropani ingroya opens three
investigations at the same time one on
the killing of pepino and pastato one on
the events at alcomo marina and one on
the alleged swiss side of pinovasco
everything that happened according to
him was done with one purpose misleading
the investigation so the questions
became from whom did the carabinieri
have the order to act as they did to
cover who or what there's no definite
answer to these questions that may be
proven by facts and this can only mean
that behind the whole maneuver there may
be someone or something very powerful
even if there's no evidence we do have a
lot of clues about what could have
happened we have a belief there's
ingroia's belief that the infamous stay
behind secret army formed by nato after
world war ii to resist from behind lines
hence its name the communist invasion of
europe by the soviet union had something
to do with it since no such invasion
ever took place the various national
rips of the organization which in italy
goes by the name gladio like the roman
sword delighted themselves with other
little games
perhaps it's no coincidence that a
series of bombings is unleashed in
europe starting with the mother of all
bombs that of piazza fontana in milan in
1969.
in belgium the brabant balloon gang
affiliated with stay behind carried out
16 assaults on supermarkets resulting in
massacres of civilians including
children at the end of which 25 were
killed and 28 wounded it may sound
curious that ingroya simultaneously
opened investigations into the events in
alcomo and the death of pepino and
pastato a death that at first absurdly
categorized as a suicide will be
attributed only much later in 2002 to
the
what relationship could there be between
gladio and the sicilian mafia also why
specifically in alchemy there is one
remarkable detail during the search of
pepino's house a folder with the heading
giuseppe vesco is found this is a
certain effect it's written in the
carbonyls report but what happens to
that file no one knows it disappears
into thin air but what the hell did the
two carbine air in the barracks have to
do with it let's focus for a moment on
the gladius secret operation after
inquiries and parliamentary questions
the existence of gladio was finally
revealed publicly by the then prime
minister julio andrealti it is october
1990 and among the many pieces of
information probably not all of them
there's also one about the deposits of
weapons and explosives that the
clandestine army had set up almost
everywhere in italy this deadpool is
called nasco in italian there is hiding
place had been the main trail that an
italian judge felicia casson followed to
shed light on the killing of three
carabineri in the northern city of
gorizia kasong was one of the first to
understand how black gangs entered the
crimes and the bombings often covered up
by our secret services and the terrorist
organizations of the time however a
thousand miles south of gorizia in the
basement of a mansion enasku a hideout
of weapons is discovered guess where in
arkham perhaps the two carbine area had
stopped some
bus carrying weapons from the arsenal
and discovered things they were not
supposed to discover ingroya has been
following mafia affairs for a long time
and excludes categorically that the
criminal organization could have
anything to do with that hideout you
have to know that a lot of mysteries of
the italian republic came to light
thanks to that people that we call
justice collaborators which for the sake
of brevity we also call pentiti repented
there have been a lot of excellent ones
just think of those from the mayana gang
those from the red brigades and even
those from the sicilian mafia and once
andrealty had revealed to the nation the
existence of gladio many whistleblowers
popped up they did it in secret
disguising their voices on the
interviews but despite everything the
information was precious the first
question that comes to mind is this what
on earth is gladios action doing in a
remote corner of sicily maybe it served
as a base a point of contact with
colleagues in the balkans north africa
and the horn of africa to do what
honestly if we have learned anything
from the unresolved death of two italian
journalists hilaria alpi and miran
it is that for many years
to those countries there was a huge
traffic of weapons and highly toxic and
radioactive waste coming from all over
the world weapons that traveled on
special aircraft both military and
international planes operated by
governments but this is just one of the
many investigations of our murky
republic there are then several
investigations linking gladio to the
mafia excellent names pop up such as
that of vito chanchimino mayor of the
city of palermo the judge giovanni
falcone himself tried to understand the
links between the mafia and gladio while
investigating the murder of the
politician piolaturi but joanna falcone
faced the wall of silence even from his
superiors we call this silence omerta
does all these have anything to do with
the massacre of the two carabineri in
the alcohol barracks actually yes
vincenzo calcada a repentant of the
mafia family of castelvetrano a town
that lies 50 kilometers south of alcamo
speaks about it calcada is an important
pentito from his confessions we begin to
understand something kalkara was in a
cell with pinovesco when he received
orders from a mafioso called antonio
messina to leave him alone in the cell
the commission to make him commit
suicide is carried out by a mobster and
two prison guards on the
responsibilities of the four arrested
palkara is crystal clear they are just
victims of no importance to the business
of the mafia yeah but what about gladio
one of the hypotheses of the massacre of
the two cabinetry is that they had seen
a weapon delivery on the coast maybe a
delivery or weapons that the mafia had
prepared for gladio or vice versa the
mobster antonio messina also doesn't
back down and tells his truth he claims
that the massacre in the barracks
happened by mistake in fact some mafia
actions against institutional
headquarters in various sicilian
municipalities had been planned at that
time the counter-order given at the last
moment hadn't arrived in alchemy and
therefore the barracks had been stormed
anyway but messina himself tells kalkara
that the two carabinieri had seen things
they were not supposed to see and so
they were prevented from harming not
cousin ostra members but those connected
to it and here we are again the mafia
gladio secret service plot an exchange
of favors in short as in many other
stories of the italian republic the
three main questions who did it why
who are the perpetrators very often
remain unanswered as the real answers
are covered from time to time by the
imposition of the state secrecy by the
misdirection of investigations carried
out by the forces that should be seeking
the truth and sometimes by people's
omerta and even by our people who stand
by and watch while the few who dare to
raise their voices end up victims of a
system that is both absurd and ruthless
all there is left is to understand how
things turned out after the acquittal
sentence for gulotta and the others not
for giovanni mandala a cancer is faster
than justice and took him away 1998.
despite everything he's found innocent
15 years after his death justice in
italy fast like internet explorer
vincenzo ferrantelli gaetano sant'angelo
the two teenagers who fled to brazil and
that was sentenced to 20 years were
compensated by the state in 2017.
requests for much larger compensation
were rejected by the government however
the most dramatic story remains that of
giuseppe gulotta there is also a book
about his history but unfortunately
there's no english translation yet there
is even a foundation named after him
with a purpose to preserve the memory of
the miscarriage of justice resulting
from the torture gulotta suffered glotta
has become a symbol of judicial errors
which if one reads the chronicles
offered by the website
erulijuditari.com judicialerrors.com
these errors well are many in our
country and cost millions of euros in
compensation each year this whole story
has focused on four unfortunate guys who
were wrongly imprisoned but i almost
forgot i almost left behind the two
killed carabineri salvatore and carmine
today in alcomo you can find a monument
made to commemorate them and every
january 27 people lay a crown in memory
of these two carabinieri and just like
that monument this video is done to keep
the memory of those two boys alive thank
you peraspera adastra